plaisir commune de plus de 31 mille
habitants membres de la communauté
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines ou trois
listes seront en lice pour le second
tour des municipales
joséphine coleman ce berger maire
sortante est arrivé en tête le 15 mars
dernier devant l'ex adjoint aux finances
patrick jean terre et l'élu d'opposition
annie joël priou a signé un scrutin
juste avant le confinement où
l'abstention a atteint 63,45 % plaisir
communes ouvertes sur la plaine de
versailles partagé entre la campagne et
la ville l'aménagement du territoire
doit trouver un équilibre entre eux
urbanisation et zones naturelles
thématiques qui prend tout son sens en
cette période de crise sanitaire
l'environnement plaisir compte une forêt
plusieurs parcs naturels est la question
des transports et de la circulation se
posent encore notamment après le récent
aménagement de la rd 30 et de la
passerelle piétons cyclistes reliant la
commune à elancourt l'urbanisation c'est
la réhabilitation du centre bourg et la
rénovation du quartier du val hibou un
investissement de 65 millions d'euros
projet d'écoquartier déjà engagé que
devra poursuivre le prochain maire de la
ville avec une prise en compte plus
globale concernant la délinquance les
questions sociales et l'emploi autre
problématique la désertification
médicale la commune est classée en zone
d'action complémentaire par l' agence
régionale de santé et des médecins
approchent de la retraite risque de ne
pas être remplacés
enfin le pôle commercial va s'agrandir
avec l'ouverture prochaine d'open sky
des emplois à la clé pour les plaisirs
war